[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
d' envies de lecture
nous sommes cinq aujourd'hui et 5 vingt
quatre invités voilà avec chacun des
envies de lecture à communiquer on va
vous présenter brièvement et dieu ce que
vous faites donc à ma droite flora tout
et bonjour bonjour flora alors qu'ils
que faites vous qui êtes vous
alors donc je suis responsable de
l'atelier des sciences c'est un service
de vulgarisation de la culture
scientifique et technique au sein de la
direction de la culture de saint quentin
en yvelines à 50 ah d'accord vous
jacques fournier
moi je dirige les itinéraires politique
de saint quentin en yvelines qui est
aussi aux services de direction du
rayonnement culturel de saint quentin en
yvelines
très bien nous passons maintenant aux
fils félix annonc ophélie félix bonjour
je suis donc responsable des arts
visuels c'est à dire que je m'occupe de
résidences d'artistes plasticiens de
d'exposition sur le site de la
commanderie mais ailleurs d'expositions
itinérantes voilà d'accord très bien et
vous corinne vrilliard jours donc moi je
suis aussi à la direction du rayonnement
culturel de l'agglomération et je suis
chargé de mission auprès de la
directrice du rayonnement culturel julia
10 des gens sur le développement de
nouveaux projets culturels très bien ok
alors j'imagine donc tous les cas tu
vous adorez lire sinon vous seriez
peut-être pas là et vous avez fait un
choix pour cette émission
quel est alors flora quel a été votre
critère de choix de libre alors moi j'ai
choisi des albums jeunesse
d'accord ce que je pense que pour avoir
envie de lire à l'âge adulte il faut
commencer dès le plus jeune âge le plus
tôt est le mieux
voilà et surtout je trouve que
au niveau des albums jeunesse il ya
vraiment des choses superbes à découvrir
même pour les adultes pour tous les
agents fait d'accord alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez choisi comme premier album
alors montré museum s'intitule mon arbre
mouais
il est édité à l'école des loisirs a
connu gerda muller il raconte l'histoire
d'un petit garçon de la ville qui passe
les vacances toutes les vacances
scolaires chez son cousin à la campagne
et son oncle et un forestier il va
découvrir l'espace forestier tout
simplement d'accord est tombé en
admiration d'un grand chêne
tricentenaire
mais au fur et à mesure de l'album
l'enfant découvre la vie dans la forêt
la faune la flore au fil des saisons
adacore donc ce n'est pas que l'été en
fait non c'est cher et il vacances
scolaires et quand chaque saison est
tout à fait ce qui est intéressant dans
ce livre ouais c'est qu'il est également
accompagnée de fiches pédagogiques
d'accord afin de l' ouvrage pour en
savoir plus sur les arbres les insectes
donc ça c'est génial avant d'aller se
balader en forêt au retour de la balade
pour voilà ce qu'on a vu
c'est élargir ses connaissances et
donner envie de regarder quoi d'observer
la forêt c'est vraiment une invitation à
apprendre à observer la nature et c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on connaît un peu plus
de choses sur la nature on est à l'affût
pour découvrir cette vous retrouver en
charente allemands surtout en été qu'il
ya plein de failles qu'on voit pas grand
chose génial on va écouter merci et vous
à quelle heure qu'avez vous à nous
proposer ça serait l'iliade d'homère
yade c'est à dire un des livres qui a
qu'à fonder la littérature mondiale
cette épopée qui raconte par le menu la
dernière année de la guerre de troie
entre les grecs et les troyens
voilà donc
ça fait partie des livres que je suis en
train de relire
est ce que vous l'avez lutte raja ben
oui et très mal très certainement très
mal donc dans le programme scolaire
c'était ou voilà c'était sûrement à ce
moment là j'en ai pu vraiment un grand
souvenir
et puis on en a une image tellement
édulcorée par toute la littérature ou le
cinéma cas puis en effet cet abominable
signe s'appelle 3 et qui ne tient compte
que de l'aspect humain du livre alors
que la part la part divine la part du
destin et les combats entre les dieux
est tout à fait intéressante et
peut-être plus intéressante que celle
des humains ou dès 2001 entre eux et
donc c'est ça qui m'a incité à vous le
proposez aujourd'hui est donc vous même
vous êtes en train de le remettre je
suis en train de vie et ce qui m'a donné
aussi une envie de le lire c'est c'est
le travail qui a mené au sylvain tesson
qu'il mène actuellement sur l'odyssée
avec ce livre qui vient de sortir aux
archipels et je suis dit voilà j'ai
envie de de revivre un petit peu
ces histoires là parce que derrière il
ya diallo 10 et c'est à dire un texte
beaucoup plus complexe le retour de
complexes aussi de glisse jusque jusque
son il est donc là l'intérêt était de
replonger un petit peu là dedans avec en
parallèle ce regard que porte et un
contemporain comme sylvain tesson grands
aventuriers grands lecteurs et est
passionné par tout ce qui concerne les
voyages et est-ce que vous pensez que
que nous autour de cette table on peut
se replonger dans le maire comme ça dans
l'eau merde importe quoi oui parce que
c'est tout c'est d'une lecture très très
simple la seule complication du livre
c'est les noms c'est qui à longueur de
temps il cite des personnages tous sont
une généalogie très complexe
et il faut voir aussi il ya une chose
qui est très intéressante dans ce livre
dans dans dans l'iliade c'est la
violence c'est à dire qu'il n'y va pas
avec le dos de la cuillère c'est à dire
que c'est une guerre continue avec des
périodes de pause où il faut récupérer
des morts prenez les brûler etc mais dès
qu'on est dans les scènes de combat on
est dans une monstruosité absolue qui
est la réalité des guerres c'est à dire
qu on des membres ont des capitons on
perce le corps de part en part avec les
lances des reins ou avec l'épée et c'est
une réalité
donc ça n'est pas du tout édulcorée et
c'est une chose qui a quasiment disparu
de la littérature contemporaine
les scènes de violence cette violence
mais cette la manière simple et directe
de le dire
c'est aussi cette manière là moi qui
m'intéresse c'est comment il ya des
siècles de cela des écrivains ou un
écrivain parce qu'on ne sait toujours
pas qui est au maire en réalité ont pu
rendre compte par l'épopée l'ancêtre du
poème
ce qu'était la réalité des guerres qui
n'arrêtait pas de 2,2
voilà qui était notre stop ok sur la
terrasse était au club ok bon d'écouter
très bien je pense que on va regarder le
riad avec un autre regard
voilà ophélie félix alors dites moi quel
est votre choix
alors moi j'ai choisi mémoires d'hadrien
de ma vraie sur saône à part au sein de
ça alors oui parce que c'est un grand
classique mais aussi parce que quand
vous avez posé la question de proposer
un livre j'ai choisi un livre qui a une
résonance particulière pour moi on me
l'a offert quand j'avais 17 ans juste
avant que je rentre à la fac et en fait
je leur lis tous les étés c'est un livre
que j'ai tellement aimé que je relis
tous les étés et que je redécouvre tous
les étés
parce que c'est extrêmement bien écrit
et que je crois que on est le un lecteur
du moment c'est à dire qu'à chaque page
de sa vie quand on aime un livre on le
relit avec un autre oeil
est ce que j'aime dans ce livre c'est
que c'est donc c'est sous forme de
lettre c'est la lettre d'adrien entre
l'empereur hadrien qui donc sur le point
de mourir et qui écrit un marc aurèle et
qui lui raconte sa vie avec
alors il ya c'est très intéressant donc
de sa façon de voir l'amour de voir la
guerre la paix la politique
les intrigues
les dieux le rapport aux dieux le
rapport aux autres leur rapport aux
hommes le rapport aux femmes
et du coup c'est quelque chose qui me
nourrit chaque fois donc j'avais envie
d'en parler parce que je pense que c'est
pas juste parce que c'est un classique
il faut le lire c'est parce que
magnifique livre non mais justement
c'est ça fait partie des livres un peu
comme les livres qu'on lit on a été
obligé de passer au visuel et voilà il
ya des livres que j'ai relu que j'ai lu
aller au but de façon moi y avoir à
l'école que j'ai relu plus tard et que
je n'ai pas du tout aimé
alors que voulait alors que alors que
jaser mais voilà et celui ci il a un
pouvoir magique sur moi j'espère qu'il y
en aura sur d'autres c'est que je trouve
qu'il est tellement bien écrit et que
c'est tellement profond on y trouve à
chaque fois une histoire différente avec
les réseaux note avec une résonance
voilà c'est fait et au pire en même
temps le hot empire romain c'est quand
même une période c'est l'âge d'or de
rome
et donc il ya une espèce de tolérance
d'ouverture de points de vue sur le
monde qui est extrêmement intéressant et
je trouve que on devrait être temps en
temps de lire ça sur le monde
contemporain
on avait créé les répercussions mais
mais je trouve qu'on devrait enfin il
faut qu'au mondial revenir à revenir
parfois à ce qui est la chose publique
l'amour des autres le respect des autres
tout ça et c'est voilà je crois que ça
s'apprend pas d'âge
ce livre là je ne sais pas parce qu'ils
ont lu ça vous donne aussi ça fait
partie des grands livres de la
littérature française ah oui c'est un
livre essentiel
j'ai lu deux fois je le dis pas felli
mais c'est parti yourcenar est une des
grandes de la littérature du xxème
siècle oui et vos flora et ophélie m'en
parle souvent d'ailleurs c'est comme si
vous l'aviez vu ça tous les étés dans
mon sac de plage ma collègue avant que
j'emporte mon livre fait d'accord
ecogreen alors dites-moi brizard qu'est
ce que vous nous présentez aujourd'hui
alors moi je vais vous présenter un
roman policier
donc encore un roman policier mais avec
une petite particularité
donc il s'agit de l'inconnu de porc
blond écrit par jean luc bannalec
alors jean luc barek de son vrai nom en
fait c'est un auteur allemand s'appelle
alors je reprends ma petite île fiche
joerger bang donc il est écrivain et
éditeur allemand est en fait il a pris
un nom à consonance bretonne parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est tombé amoureux
de la bretagne est le prétexte de ce
livre qui est un roman policier parmi
beaucoup de romans policiers c'est en
fait le quatrième livre d'une série de
cinq qui l'a écrit pour l'instant de
cinq romans policiers dont le personnage
principal est le commissaire du pin
auquel on va vraiment s'attacher tout au
long des différents romans la vraie
particularité moi j'ai c'est ce que
j'aime en fait dans cette série de
livres de romans policiers pour être
plus exact c'est que en fait le l'auteur
va nous raconter la bretagne
les bretons leur métier leur style de
vie et tout un tas de traits de
caractère des personnages au fur et à
mesure des livres donc les histoires
alors certes il ya une trame de romans
policiers alors on aime on n'aime pas le
style du roman policier mais bon c'est
une petite intrigue qui va nous servir
de fil rouge mais dans tout le long de
tout au long de 2 des différentes sommes
en fait il a pu écrire on découvre ou
hong re découvre pour suivant les cas la
bretagne ses paysages
et puis les habitants leur métier et
vraiment c'est moi c'est quelque chose
que je trouve sympathique c'est un très
bon roman loisirs réalité va pas tarder
à arriver
ledroit hier matin exactement céder ce
sont des voyages en bretagne super donc
ça change de lieu en bretagne
ça change de lieu de bronze également
chaque fois tout à fait bien pour
terminer on va faire un petit tour de
table alors qu'elle est quel est votre
actu vous flora oui elle aurait
actuellement nous avons en collaboration
avec objet d ophélie la restitution
d'une résidence arts et sciences autour
de l'artiste ma floués passe doit donc
la restitution se dire quoi donc vous
avez repris 5 est rendu alors toute
l'année elle a travaillé sur des
créations d'installation ouais
accompagné également de scientifiques
d'accord qu'elle présente son exposition
intitulée entre voir l'invisible
d'accord donc c'est à découvrir à la
commanderie nous avons aussi de nombreux
ateliers tous les mercredis et samedis
hockey à l'action bare bones on parlera
dans d'autres émissions et vous jacques
alors samedi à 10 heures à la
médiathèque jean rousseau de rencontre
avec le poète et plasticien il bergeret
qui a travaillé avec des collégiens en
de guyancourt et la semaine suivante
pendant toute la semaine notre présence
avec d'autres
lieu de poésie maison de poésie festival
sur le marché de la poésie de paris
place saint sulpice
merci tous les quatre a très vite pour
une nouvelle émission si bien au revoir
et merci
[Musique]